okay if you're in Jacksonville there's
no team nearby there's like obviously
the Hawks up top and then down below
it's really the magic of the closest
team like who do you want to imagine
um
what in basketball yeah and basketball
I'm a LeBron James fan I love it I go
with LeBron go yeah and then in football
you obviously love the Jaguars or I mean
that's got to be tough right just uh
growing up watching like uh mediocrity
or subpar football your whole childhood
hey watch
Jones Drew was a beast UCLA man he was a
very tiny tiny Stout dude I was a Jones
roof and that I had the Jones did you
play fantasy football because he was a
beast in fantasy no I played fantasy
football I ain't really big I feel like
people go to Jacksonville to get good
and then they get traded
like Jalen Ramsey Jalen Ramsey we had
Leonard fournette fournette was a beast
had to go to he went to Tampa
we can we can slip up a good roster I
can't deny that place was there can't
deny that at all but this team we got
you know I'm saying coming this year I
feel like we're gonna be Trevor Lawrence
you know Lawrence yeah Trevor Lawrence
holding it down he ain't scared her name
and he out there playing on the east
side well you know I'm saying the heart
of Jacksonville it's my side so he good
that's where the stadium is yep have you
seen Trevor Lawrence out in public
anywhere yeah I don't see any trouble
Lawrence out in public I feel like you
guys like you should take him out like a
night on the town through little puppies
yeah for sure Trevor Lawrence if you
ever see this anybody if y'all get this
to Trevor Lawrence the Duval way
come on come aim it's the only way you
feel me you are playing on the east side
every day you feel me you coming through
my hood you know what I'm saying come on
why not stop through it
um for you man like obviously I just
looking you up on YouTube there's so
many like random documentaries about
your life and what's going on yeah how
much of that [__] is like frustrating
because I'm sure a lot of it is [__]
but people watch I mean a lot of the
stuff tons of views so it's like people
watch that come to come to their own
conclusions like I can only imagine if
you look to me my name up and there was
people making many documentaries about
my life that was inaccurate I hate them
in a documentary so much because and you
never know what the guy looks like it's
just a voice everything false yeah you
feel me like it gonna take a little
pieces of it you know what I'm saying of
what you don't let out to the world and
everything else is just built off their
assumptions uh fans assumptions it's all
assumptions it's like it's like they're
trying to control the name that [__] is
so much false it's so much fiction and
then it's like
Right Out playing with people life
people Freedom out there like stop
playing 100 man [__]
um growing up in Jacksonville what are
you doing for fun are you hooping
obviously you're making music are you
watching Netflix are you playing 2K what
do you do for fun as a kid coming up
where you're from man coming up in
Jacksonville like
it's best to like
be from a hood a filmmakers ain't too
much going on like in like the nice
areas
like nothing going on at all so if you
like in the hood then you've got
something going on every day like what
are you doing like I mean every time I
stop talking about like you getting into
the streets I'm talking about like nine
you're talking about like getting in the
streets like that's what a fun that you
feel me in the neighborhood like we used
to go to just ride ride to be able to go
outside and ride your bike every day you
know what I'm saying that was fun for us
like we didn't go nowhere you know what
I'm saying they consider it fun we had a
little [__] like Adventure Landing you
know what I'm saying like that was like
our little water park arcade but that
[__] was ran down you know what I'm
saying you got the beach you feel me
that's it but other than that the
neighborhood you know I'm saying the the
the neighborhood pool going to the
Kennedy Center
uh uh like you told my like can't get
out in a restaurant
yeah
I'll be talking to my boy in the pool
while I'm peeing yes no idea
I'll just be like yeah yeah that's right
especially if the water's cold it'll
warm you up bro don't play don't let
that water be too cold yeah pissing this
water real quick so I got the chlorine
for a reason you know what I'm saying uh
yeah we got lighters everywhere
yeah come on
oh Brittany no this is one of the only
on the interviews you get the smoke on
so why not smoking
where'd you go to where were you guys at
before this uh
um
assuming you're not smoking a serious
right no no
my face looks at me you stole Christmas
laptop well I won't go down that uh
rabbit hole with you and my thoughts
what was on there was there was there oh
[__]
see she's a thief
just know the newest employee of CMG
steals
you go check that out
and she's the interview Nazi Mane you
know what I mean I can't wait to get her
notes after this one
um
she'll be like can you edit out all of
the marijuana
would you start smoking weed how old
were you I was it's crazy I started
smoking late I was like 17 18 you know
that's not terrible I smoked weed for
the first time when I was eight
but I didn't like get into it but I
tried it for the first time when I was
there I smoked for the first time too
when I was like 12. and it burned like I
just remember being like it hurt I'm
like how why do people how do people do
this yeah I remember God for the first
time too I like what's the point
have you ever smoked out of a soda can
nah ain't no smoke some holes in the
middle of that [__] you smoke I have an
apple
I ain't smoking I don't know Apple
neither
it's a thing you know I used to live in
Florida I used to live in Tampa which is
not obviously very close to where you're
at but it ain't far neither not far
either right in the middle man right in
the middle how much uh do you still try
to pay attention to like the new wave of
what's going on at a Jacksonville and
like maybe try to help out like if
there's somebody you're feeling that
maybe isn't signed you you're gonna
throw them a free feature look out for
sure for sure uh you talking about like
in Jacksonville yeah just in your city
um
I like I don't really be like on social
media like that like so when I
um when I do hear something like new
like new artists coming out of
Jacksonville my little brother put me on
it right you know what I'm saying and
and if he rocking with it if you think
it's hard then it's hard because he just
listening to know anything he like me
when it comes to music so
when you when you're recording are you
writing [__] down are you punching in
like give me your process what's your
process when you're recording
punching in I go into I go in the studio
you know I'm trying to pull me up some
beats go through some beats I'll
probably send by a good
10 of them you know what I'm saying and
I'm gonna try to do at least five of
them at that 10 pack before the night
over it
so you're like hum like a melody and
then go in and
yep honestly that's it because you're
pretty you're a lot more melodic than a
lot of the Jacksonville [__] that's
popping like in terms of like you know
you actually have a lot of Melody in
your music so yeah a lot of the other
[__] like it's just very like you know I
want to learn how to aggressive
yeah I wanna know how to sing it's a
definitely a lot of regression coming
out of Jacksonville but it's a lot of
you feel me it's a lot hey why can't
Cyrus you feel me it's a lot of you know
what I'm saying it's a lot of
Versatility I don't know what I'm saying
she's got to be I feel like there's
somebody else I'm forgetting that sings
for my tripping
oh it's a lot
like Hill Cyrus shout out I know for
sure you gotta get your [__] together
right here you can sing for sure I know
so I was saying you could probably help
him out right do a record with him
help him out throw him the lot man yeah
I mean he'll make money that little pop
alive afterwards recent events leave it
in God's hands for show